hey what's up guys my name is China
welcome back to my game engine series so
today we've got a very very exciting
episode but maybe not maybe to leave
starting to some people it's actually
pretty exciting to me even though it
might be considered objectively tame but
today we're gonna be talking about
references and smart pointers and all of
that fun stuff that we just need to
consider for kind of our core engine
because this kind of stuff is stuff that
you kind of just brush under the rug
it's stuff that everyone loves to just
ignore and then eventually all of your
technology will come crashing down
because you just didn't consider this
back in the day of you kind of beginning
this stuff so last time we talked about
something else that I can't even
remember what did we talk about last
time shader abstraction and uniform so
check out that video if you haven't
already had to check that out for me
because I'm so focused on today's
episode which is references and small
pointers and unique pointers and how all
that system works okay so enough kind of
fluff enough of that crap we're gonna
actually get into it now
so what is going on right now with our
code pretty much everywhere we're using
this kind of shared pointer thing we're
you know just we need to create a shader
so it needs to be created on the heap so
what do we do we encapsulate it inside a
shared pointer object for two purposes
first of all because we want to control
the lifetime of this object we want to
somewhat tie the ownership to sandbox
app but also make it so that if this app
kind of gets destroyed or any scope that
we're dealing with gets destroyed this
object too will get destroyed because
it's a shared pointer provided there are
no other references to it now we could
have used the unique point if you had no
reason kind of not to rewrite you would
think you know just type in unique
pointer scoped it I think some people
actually did suggest that in the
comments though why is this not a unique
pointer because it needs to be you know
clearly the lifetime is tied to this it
can't exist outside of sandbox app or
anything like that should we be using
unique pointer now smart pointers are
interesting because they kind of provide
us with a system that helps us write
they're there to help us they're there
to say that you're not gonna actually
call delete are you will handle that for
you based
the kind of traits of the object that
you're kind of shoving into that smart
pointer now I have a video on smart
pointers I even have a video in the C++
series specifically about what I think
of smart pointers now I think that has
changed in that video I think isn't
necessarily about what I think of them
but it's just how I think they should be
taught because I think there's a lot of
emphasis on smart pointers these days
and people getting really angry in
comments in my comments being like why
why did you know just write new did you
know just write delete why that's wrong
the point is smart pointers are
fantastic I wouldn't leave without smart
pointers because if smart pointers
didn't exist I would just write a smart
pointer class and just we would just use
that but the problem is more it's kind
of deeper than that the problem is the
fact that it's not just about new and
delete it's not just about abstracting
that away and especially automating that
delete part it's 50% of it if not more
it's about ownership it becomes a
question of ownership right this is now
owned by something if we make this a
unique point I guess what that means
that this sandbox class literally owns
that shadow right because if it doesn't
own that change some of the sandbox
classes the example a class but the
point is that example a class literally
owns that shader why it's nothing you
can do you can't copy you can't hand
over ownership that's it when that
example layer gets popped off the layer
stack because the application is closed
because we want to transition to a new
level because we want to do anything
like that right as soon as that dies
that's it our shadows wiped off the face
of the earth it the memory is released
Kabir instantly reclaimed it's gone
right I want to suggest that that is
actually an issue that's a problem we
can't have that we literally can't have
that because right now if that were to
happen I think we'd probably be ok but
you have to consider the bigger picture
let's take a look at a renderer let's
have a think about what our renderer
would be like if it was actually you
know a solid renderer and not just like
a bunch of functions and you know I mean
we're on our way we're on our way we're
gonna get there but right now this
renderer is
you know very very bare-bones if we had
a real renderer let's have a think of
what that would look like okay so we
have a renderer submission right we call
hazel renderer submit what does that do
well at the moment it takes in a shader
in the future as I said it would take in
a material potentially but right now it
takes in a shader what have we done
we've submitted a shader for rendering
we've submitted a vertex array for
rendering of vertex array that's also an
asset right any kind of asset is going
to be a pointer essentially it's gonna
be a heap allocated object and
eventually probably not allocated in the
heap but allocated in kind of our memory
arena or something like that vertex
array is a it's it's it's a resource
it's an asset that we need to actually
use to render that and we have a
transform now I transform that's a map
for I mean argue belief you're just not
really a real asset you could if you
wanted to 64 bytes of data you probably
copy that and you take that and that's
it you can just deal with that but
shaders write that shader that vertex
array their actual assets right what I
mean by that is we can't just like
decide that if I want to retain an asset
I'll copy it that should never be done
because it's an asset you know this
might be huge
right I mean I sure it might just be
like a opengl ID or something but for
all intents and purposes it's an asset
so what are we done we've submitted it
for rendering rendering what did I what
I said about rendering all this time
it's deferred right you will not be
rendering stuff immediately if we look
at submit right now it calls render
command at draw indexed what is it doing
its immediately drawing not gonna happen
in the future right because as I talked
about we need to be able to have a
context of an entire scene that we want
to actually render before we start
rendering right so before we actually
start even rendering one single object
on the screen I want to have practically
the full scene of everything because I
need to do sorting I need to do actual
like calling potentially right I need to
bash things together and improve the
performance so many things I might want
to do right I have to have the whole
scene in order to do that so that I
don't do be inefficient rendering
because that would be bad especially for
us because we're trying to be all cool
and hip and trend
so the point is I need to take this
shader object that has just been given
to me and I need to kind of hold a
reference to it if I don't hold a
reference to it that's gonna be
problematic the vertex are a same thing
I need that vertex array later right how
later well I mean I don't know in the
future I'm gonna render this in the
future so first of all set one's render
at rendering is deferred now step two
most engines are multi-threaded right
you would not run an engine on a single
thread I don't think that's ever
happened but well it's definitely
happened before but I don't think
recently any engine really that has
shipped a game as well we shipped on a
single thread why because your computer
your device that you're on has multiple
cores multiple actual like virtual
threads it has a system for dealing with
stuff at the same time so if you're
literally not doing that you're just
wasting potential performance stuff that
you could get for free you're just
wasting it right it's kind of like
having a gas stove you have like five
different things you need to cook here
to fry up this you need four out that
all in separate pans and you use one of
your gas burners right if you've got an
electric stove for some reason then you
know adapt that metaphor to that but my
point is what you wouldn't do that you'd
use all four burners I came up with this
on the spot by the way I before is like
perfect because a lot of things have
like four cores and anyway the point is
you're we're not gonna use a single
burner at a time that's silly right all
your food's gonna get cold you're gonna
use all four burners at once you could
create this masterpiece when is cooking
with China coming very soon but my point
is that you're not gonna do that you're
gonna actually use each stove same same
thing here you wouldn't just right
imagine that uses a single thread
because that's somewhat silly
so because we use multiple threads in
our engine that read the command cue
that we've kind of deferred that all the
stuff that our renderer has to do that's
going to run on a separate thread what
that means is that while our current
kind of thread our game thread our
updated our application thread whatever
while bad is just you know submitting
data to the renderer the renderer is
actually at the same time processing
rendering that previous frame worth of
data okay so what we end up with
effectively is something that is one
friend behind now what happens is once
that once that application has finished
submitting everything it needs to do for
this current frame it will move on to
the next frame while the renderer
renders that frame consider this we've
changed our level right well we've don't
know we've released an object from
memory because the application thread is
done with it right now that up that
let's just say that's example layer
we've released example layer from memory
right it's gone however next time we
roll around to the next frame that our
renderer is going to want to render
right that shader object that vertex
array has been deleted so explosion
nothing gets rented we crash tears
everywhere probably from just everyone
everyone all of you crying at the same
time ridiculous right so we can't have
that what that means is that in some
form or another that render thread has
to actually have a strong reference to
that object strong reference meaning
that it has a reference that is somewhat
counts as like ownership meaning that
until that reference is released if the
object is not freed from memory this
sounds exactly like a reference count
system right that's a ref count system
okay shed pointer is a ref count system
that's why we're using shed pointers at
the moment
now here's another little curveball and
by the way that little explanation there
just keep in mind that that that is why
I personally think that pretty much
every object in your engine should
probably be a shed pointer people may
make people may say that that's
inefficient you have to use unique
pointer in a lot of cases and I would
probably maybe agree but nor because the
performance overhead is so negligible
from using a set point or a very unique
pointer in certain situations one
hundred percent you might want to use a
unique pointer but to be honest I think
from experience and I'm just kind of
thinking back in my head now most of the
times where that has been the case
I have just used a roll pointer because
just because right I don't think if I'm
dealing with that kind of stuff where
performance is such an issue I'll mostly
usually use roll pointers not just but
not because unique point is a slow of
course they're not they have zero
overhead it's because that kind of code
base that requires that is most likely
going to benefit from a roll pointer you
could still enclose it in you could
still encapsulate in slight a unique
pointer if you wanted to but from
experience probably not something that
I've actually done the point is that
unique pointers are great and you might
want to use them but in pretty much all
cases especially right now when you're
not when you're not just bottlenecked by
the fact that you're sharing 90% of your
thread time is because SharePoint is
incrementing and decrementing references
that's not the case so every single
asset in the engine that gets submitted
to the render thread especially should
be a shared pointer and that's kind of
what we're dealing with now before we
get into the code we take a look at this
because what I want to do is change the
way that we actually present share
pointers like just change the way they
look and you'll see what I mean in a
minute before we get into that I just
want to quickly mention shared pointers
do have overhead right now I've just
mentioned that it's negligible and I'm
probably right but in at some certain
situations maybe we decide that we don't
want a shared pointer necessarily right
because shed pointers do a few things I
mean first of all they're not an
intrusive rep count object meaning the
reference count is not stored as part of
the actual object that you've allocated
it's stored in a separate control block
which in most cases is going to be in
line with your object so that's somewhat
negates that issue the other issue that
we could potentially face if we're
nitpicking is thread safety so shared
pointers are thread safe meaning that
the way that they achieve that thread
safety specifically is they use an
atomic increment and an atomic decrement
detriment decrement I don't never say
that word
anyway they decrement decrement
decrement is gonna be decrement they
decrement an increment the pointers that
the reference count atomically which is
fantastic for thread safety means we'll
never get
eras really but that obviously has to
lock everything up and do that atomic
increment decrement that stuff takes
time could potentially add a little bit
of overhead now look I'm not gonna argue
with you
I'm not one of those just crazy people
who will absolutely fight over such a
small like in reality such a small kind
of hitch in performance right especially
because there's so many other things we
could optimize but since it could be a
problem and since we might want to say
ah we don't need thread safety we want
to just run fast although we weren't run
fast with this but you know just bear
with me we might want to change it into
our own kind of account object right
which would fall intensive purposes
probably be a shared pointer class like
it'd probably be exactly the same except
it would do the normal increment
decrement is at an atomic one because of
that we might not want to change in the
future
for whatever reason shared pointers
might not be something we stick with
forever so because of that it has gonna
be very difficult change because we have
to find replace all Chad pointers and
replacing with something else maybe in
some cases we actually do want to use
SharePoint as though all right so what
we need right now is well as two issues
there's that which I've just mentioned
but there's also the fact that STD shed
pointer everywhere kind of looks a bit
ugly no it's not the worst thing in the
world but it kind of looks ugly so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna create our
little type that is essentially a ship
it's gonna be a shared pointer right now
in the future it could blossom into its
own type where it's like you know
actually a class and everything but for
right now we're just gonna change it so
that it's gonna be our own thing and
that's gonna be it's gonna be it's gonna
be called a ref so it's gonna be called
a hazel ref okay and what we'll do is
for the unique pointers we'll also
create a hazel obscure right so we have
a scope and we have a ref so the scope
kind of pointer is gonna be our hazel
scope thing and then our ref is gonna be
a shared pointer so unique pointer scope
because that's what it is it's just a
scope and our reference we're gonna call
ref so let's take a look at what that's
gonna look like and see if it makes our
codebase look nice up all right so the
first thing that we're going to do is
go to our core H file which contains
pretty much all of the core stuff and
I'm going to add a namespace called
hazel right nothing too special there
and then what we're going to do is
create essentially a type def so we're
going to use using for our two different
types so scope being a scope pointer
right so this will be a unique pointer
and then we're also going to create wrap
for our ref countered object which is a
shared pointer so because of course we
want this to work with templates that's
why we're actually using using apart
from the fact that using is the thing to
use these days it also enables us to
actually define us as a template so we
have a template I've named tape and then
this just goes here and now what we can
actually do is use scope with a you know
a type when we actually make it whenever
we end up using it so this is obviously
vital because otherwise this wouldn't
really work we'd have to like and and I
mean that's the other thing like you
could definitely do stuff like you know
let's just say we had a shader class
right
instead of writing RAF shader which you
currently have to do and this is as
opposed to you know STD shared pointer
so what's what is basically done is
enabled us to change this card into
you're just simply writing ref shader
and if we're outside of the hazal
namespace we'll have to do that kind of
shows you very easily that it says it's
a Hazeltine unique pointer we would do
subscribe right but apart from doing
that you could also create your own
using we're basically shader ref is a
new type that is that right and if you
do that a lot maybe that might make
sense that's not something that we
particularly care about that's another
common way to do this where basically
you just define you type you know at the
end of your shader class officially in
shade up up H I mean we could
potentially just add like they're using
shader reft
people's you know either yesterday she
had points our shader or whatever or you
could just simply in this case just
write ref shader but I think ref shader
is like is not too difficult to write
and I don't I don't like creating a
billion different types so because of
that you can basically just stick with
this now this is all the code that we
need right it's really
simple what it means in the future is we
can simply just change this scope thing
you know to be an actual template so
type name what am i doing template type
name team and then you know class score
or whatever and then we can just make a
class out of it if we want to and we
don't need to change anything in our
code base as long as we're we've used
scope and ref as a lot of those api's
that consistent with shared pointer and
you need to point out anyway that's done
super-exciting what we'll do is we'll
include memory up here just in case we
include this header file we don't want
to suddenly have issues if this header
files like included before another one
and suddenly doesn't know what STD you
need pointer or share pointer ah so
we'll just include memory up here and
then we can start changing everything
okay those are the fun part so what
we'll do is for all of this stuff again
if we wanted it to be a unique pointer
we will just do hazel scope because
we're in the sandbox class right now and
we haven't we're not inside the hazel
namespace but of course we want
everything to be a ref that is a
resource so we'll put this in and of
course one other thing that I wanna
quickly mention is this does not in any
way interfere with the with the
possibility of having like an asset
manager system this like honestly in a
very rough way is kind of like an asset
manager system since we're reference
counting everything we know that if I
give an asset if anyone is holding a
reference so in other words if anyone
requires any given asset for any reason
that asset will start that asset will
stay alive but as soon as like you know
we've basically unloaded a level right
the level classes like gone and we don't
have we don't need this asset anymore it
can it will get released from memory
well don't you want that I mean it in a
real engine you probably wouldn't want
that right because assets can be shared
between levels and you yeah you kind of
have this whole system as well so in
other words in the future we will have
an asset manager welcome probably
control the ownership in more kind of a
finer grained fashion than just by
having it as a shared pointer but this
is a fantastic start and if you just
need to like have a quick little asset
system in your game engine like honestly
just use SharePoint is that great so
that's pretty much done I think for this
class really all I'm gonna do is just
search for STD I don't think we've got
too many of these but STD shared pointer
across my entire solution maybe the
entire solution was a was I'm not
necessary we actually do have a quite a
lot of them of course but we use them
everywhere right for things like this so
this just becomes a ref and you can see
that because we're inside hazel we don't
need to do anything we can just change
this to be ref and I guess we'll just
work through all of these basically and
change them all to be ref there might be
quite a lot of them okay so we have like
you know we have them up here as well
now nor note this right I'm not changing
them here this I'm leaving as STV share
pointer the point of this is not to just
rename the standard template library and
just create our own version of it no
that's silly right I mean we're not
gonna we could type def string STD
string to just be like string with upper
case with an uppercase s and that would
be like our string class right no I
don't want to try to do that what we're
trying to do is share some line as to
what is like a Hazel reference and what
is like you know and I see you share
pointer this is like this is a log thing
right we're still gonna use shared
pointers in our code if we want to but
for things that are explicitly hazel
only write things that maybe in the
future would be handled by an asset
manager so in other words assets right
that's the kind of stuff we're trying to
rename into reps and like you know scope
pointers as well so that's why we're
gonna just leave these alone okay let's
see vertex array for example see how
this is returning like an index buffer
clearly that index buffer is simply a
it's like it's an asset so we just
return a reference and this is returning
a vector and this stuff is well vertex
buffers and index buffers those are also
assets that looks pretty good now let's
look at render API we have this yeah so
I'll just rename this you guys can I get
the point of this I probably just cut
the video here in just myself but I'll
still drive it it's just in case we run
into anything fun or and or unusual okay
and then render CVP
we renamed this stuff really does make
our code a lot cleaner as well that's
one of the things that I like about
doing this I gave what a bunch of these
things and this needs to be a hazel wrap
a bunch of these all of our data that we
create inside our example layout yeah
that looks pretty good
I'll just do a another search again for
SharePoint err okay so we're looking a
lot better we've got stuff in log but
that's again that's totally fine we're
gonna leave that alone and then there's
a bunch of stuff in OpenGL that text
array I could again I could do a finer
place but you'll notice I'm doing this
manually just because sometimes like we
want the hazel namespace sometimes we
don't want the hazel namespace and so
because of that's just easy you know if
it is though I can easily just find a
place that it's just a ref in this
current document because that will just
work out nicely okay cool
that should be it again I'll do another
search just to be like a hundred percent
sure okay so now the only reference as
you can see in a search I inside log and
call which is fantastic so we're not
using smart pointers basically anywhere
eyes and we're not using SharePoint or
anywhere except that a log class we're
just simply using hazel ref which is
pretty cool all right obviously we're
gonna try and compile this code make
sure that we make any mistakes and I
mean it should compile and run as usual
all right so we get no compile errors
and now if I try and run this code we
should get the same result as last time
where we have our kind of weld here and
everything seems to be working correctly
now I hope you guys enjoyed this video
if you did if you hit the like button
you can help support this series and
everything I do here on YouTube by going
patreon account for size to show no huge
thank you as always to all the lovely
patrons that make this series possible
started doing new exclusive videos as I
mentioned last time where basically if
you support even for as little as three
dollars a month you get access to a
whole bunch of exclusive videos in the
last one I actually showed a bunch of
like the hazel development branch and I
think that I actually am gonna put that
video off his be my already
just kind of share that exclusive video
with kind of all of you in general but
there's just tons of stuff to kind of
explore there as well as access to the
hazel development branch source code in
which this stuff and much much more
including like physically based
rendering and like animation and a whole
bunch of stuff has already been done and
obviously it helps support this series
and just ensures that I can keep making
these videos full-time because that's my
this is my full-time job right now which
is really really cool and that's all
thanks to you guys and I'm super excited
for it for the future I'll see you guys
next time goodbye
[Music]